horrific dives into the past modernist
AI nightmares and so much more with
Black Mirror season 6 available to watch
now on streamberry or we mean Netflix
here's an explanation of all the Twisted
endings
Jones seems to have it all everything
that is except control over her own life
a nice apartment a loving boyfriend and
a position of authority at her workplace
but none of it feels like something she
chose when she is forced to fire a
dedicated employee and evades
responsibility for it her morale
couldn't be any lower that is until she
sees a show seemingly targeted directly
at her on stringberry titled Joan is
awful well we're watching it no we're
not watching Joan is awful whatever the
hell it is just
play serious at first and then horrified
she discovers that Joan is awful is
based directly on her and her actual
life Joan immediately spirals as she
sees all of her worst moments slightly
exaggerated for dramatic purposes in the
capable hands of the person playing Joan
Salma Hayek with the current anxiety
around Ai and chat gbt potentially
replacing creatives Jonah's awful
couldn't have dropped at a better time
Joan is forced to learn that she has
signed away her likeness to stream very
simply by signing their massive user
agreement when she first subscribed she
teams up with Salma Hayek who signed
over the rights for her own likeness to
be used as a digital Creation in the
show to get back at the people that have
tarnished their images storming the
stream Berry HQ they discover that a
quantum computer has been using AI to
render these targeted reality shows and
in the big twist they find that their
reality is in turn a show for the
original Joan Source drone lives in
reality when Source Joan watches the TV
show Joan is awful she sees you playing
her that show is the fictive level we're
on right now here the episode has a
happy ending by the time the credits
roll but it doesn't reduce the message
by preying on relevant fears of
intrusive technology and the worrying
question of whether even our private
lives are secret Joan is awful takes a
meta approach to storytelling that will
make most viewers squirm but there's
also hope Joan ultimately takes control
of her own life rather than worry about
what others expect of her and we see the
quantum computer destroyed and Joan back
in the captain's seat of her reality in
and of itself the world of True Crime
can feel like a Black Mirror episode
novice journalists with good intentions
a desire for fame and an unwarranted
level of faith and Justice contribute to
a massively popular genre that is
regularly criticized for re-traumatizing
survivors of violent crime while there's
often Nuance to the conversation in real
life it isn't Nuance that filmmakers Pia
and Davis and Loch Henry are looking for
when they start digging into local lore
around Ian Adair Ian was a serial killer
who lured tourists into his basement to
be tortured he ultimately wounded
Davis's father and according to his
mother Janet caused health problems that
led to Davis's father's eventual death
yet things are not all as they seem
while Davis is in the hospital
recovering from a car crash Pia pulls
out one of Janet's VHS tapes labeled
Bergerac a long-running British crime
show from the 1980s focused on
particularly unsettling cases on the
tape instead of an old BBC detective
drama she discovers horrifying footage
of Davis's parents torturing a couple to
death with Ian Adair
Ken gave me that
we had such fun together Pia attempts to
flee but suffers a fatal injury While
Janet who knows her secret is out dies
by Suicide leaving the rest of her
gruesome home movies for her son though
Davis's documentary wins Awards the lens
of True Crime has been refocused on him
alone with the most painful things that
have ever happened to him up for public
consumption Davis has gotten what he
wanted but paid a terrible price for it
David and Cliff are astronauts in deep
space with technology that allows them
to transport their Consciousness into
robotic forms back on Earth to help them
cope with the lengthy time away when
David's Earth robot is destroyed and his
family killed by a cult that's convinced
mechanical life is an Abomination cliff
and his wife Lana invite David to use
Cliff's link for an hour every week to
help him cope of course that situation
starts getting weird David develops a
crush on Lana who rejects him but
Cliff's desire to control Lana their son
and even David's grief process leads to
tragedy when David returns to take
Cliff's family away just as he lost his
own having it all might make a person
feel Invincible but in the end we can't
control what life takes Cliff's arrogant
belief that he can control the situation
blows up in his face and with his power
gone he and David become true equals for
the first time though the episode ends
on an open-ended note with David kicking
a chair to Cliff and inviting him to
metaphorically and literally sit at the
same table it's clear that neither has
anything left to live for whether they
continue on or don't no longer matters
whatever they do they'll have to do it
together set in 2006 Maisie day takes on
classic horror genre tropes by matching
the hunger of a werewolf with the
unscrupulous behavior of mid-out's
Paparazzi protagonist Beau takes a photo
that ruins an actor's life and leads to
his death by Suicide while she's told
this is not her fault it forces her to
leave the business that is until the
Starlet Maisie day vanishes off the face
of the planet after leaving a film
mid-shoot driving up interest in photos
of her after following her to a rehab
Clinic Beau and her fellow photographers
are shocked to discover Maisie day isn't
suffering from standard celebrity dramas
rather she has been transformed into a
werewolf
though Beau and her peers attempt to
flee the werewolf makes short work of
them until Beau is able to get in a
single shot that grounds the Beast
bloody naked and weeping Maisie day begs
boat to kill her but bow Ops instead to
hand her a gun so that she can catch it
all on film with Maisie crying and
holding a gun to her head and both
finger hovering over the shutter The
Parallel between these two very
different kinds of shooting couldn't be
clearer while this might seem like a
departure for the series the fact is
that there is nothing more Black Mirror
than commentary on the toxicity of
Paparazzi culture indeed this episode
only pulls overarching themes together
more than ever by revealing that
Humanity's various dystopias can't be
blamed on technology alone taking place
in England in 1979 demon 79 centers on
Nida a South Asian woman working in a
shoe store she's regularly forced to
deal with racist aggression as her
co-worker expresses open resentment
toward her and her culture Nida copes
through violent fantasies of Destruction
and Mayhem but leads a relatively quiet
and assuming life that is until she
accidentally splashes a rune with her
own blood inadvertently summoning the
demon Gap who tells her that she needs
to kill three people to avoid the
apocalypse let's stop it happening we
have those deliver free sacrifices in
free days it's only three killings
noting that there is a surplus of truly
reprehensible people surrounding Nita
GOP coaxes her along as she targets who
she will kill a well-meaning policeman
stops her just short of her goal and
well just as God promised the apocalypse
happens still things aren't all bad as
GOP invites Nita along to endure
nothingness with him implying that it
might not be so bad if at least they're
not alone while demon 79 is a farce
based on nuclear anxiety late 70s
xenophobia and unaddressed mental health
issues its heart shows us a bleak level
of horror where even basically good acts
might not save us from Humanity's worst
in the end while Nida has a relatively
happy ending there is no denying that
her time on Earth in this episode is
majorly defined by other people's racism
without which neither the murders nor
the apocalypse would happen
this season of Black Mirror features
several Easter eggs and references to
past episodes the most notable of which
hinge on its in-universe streaming giant
streamberry a stand-in for Netflix
itself from the catchy name down to the
flashy logo and user interface and Joan
is awful there is a moment of
foreshadowing for The Following episode
when the documentary lock Henry truth
will out appears alongside a number of
other self-referential films and shows
these include documentaries like finding
ripman calling back to the lead
antagonist of bandersnatch and the
callow years Ananda Michael callow from
the first episode The National Anthem
besides a handful of other strainberry
in-jokes there are a few references to
the White Bear symbol that first appears
in the season 2 episode of the same name
first in Beyond the Sea the
anti-robotics cult members that attacked
David's family scroll the symbol in
blood on a wall and in Demon 79 the
symbol appears on the Rune that Nida
finds and accidentally splashes with a
drop of her blood during her vision of
the future politician Michael smartz
Britannia party logo also Bears a
striking similarity to the mysterious
glyph you probably recognize him he's
all set to be our next MP well with a
little look and a following win
speaking of smart his name appears in a
new scroll in lock Henry that announces
his robot police dogs foreshadowing The
Bleak future seen in the season 4
episode Metalhead meanwhile the TV
series Sea of Tranquility another
recurring Black Mirror reference makes
an appearance in Joan is awful as one of
the shows available for streaming and in
Maisie day Beau outs the star of Sea of
Tranquility Justin camley by taking
photos of him meeting a lover at a hotel
these aren't nearly all the references
to Prior episodes to be found in season
six and for some fans part of the fun of
black mirror is trying to catch them all
as always the Anthology format of Black
Mirror explores the interactions between
technology and Humanity taken to their
extremes this season achieves this by
shaking up the timeline a bit more than
it has before implementing just as many
nods to Modern Life as ever while also
delving into the past in three of its 5
episodes while Joan is awful shows a
woman forced to see the immediate echo
of everything she does on a TV screen
lock Henry warns of the potential
hazards of dredging up the past followed
by three episodes that are trips to the
yesteryear of the Black Mirror shared
Universe by starting with a tail set so
firmly in the present as many Black
Mirror episodes are then using the last
episodes to travel backward as the show
never has before this season pointedly
refuses Nostalgia for any perceived good
old days before technology came along
and ruined everything instead it fleshes
out a central theme that technology is
essentially benign and it's the hand in
which it rests that determines whether
it achieves good or ill it's important
to note that characters that are against
technology run amok such as the cult and
Beyond the Sea are completely detached
from reality this adds an overall sense
that learning from our mistakes with
tech might be a healthier approach than
denying its benefits outright much of
this season revolves around a slightly
more optimistic view that even in the
worst possible outcomes there is always
a silver lining somewhere as of this
video Netflix has not officially
greenlit a season 7 of Black Mirror but
considering the ongoing hype around the
series it seems unlikely that the plug
will be pulled anytime soon it confirmed
their innermost fears and put them in a
state of mesmerized horror
which really drives engagement series
Creator Charlie Brooker told to Doom
that any season of the series will have
to subvert expectations even if that
means subverting his own at times I've
always felt that Black Mirror should
feature stories that are entirely
distinct from one another and keep
surprising people and myself or else
what's the point it should be a series
that can't be easily defined and can
keep Reinventing itself with six seasons
in the bag this approach is clearly
what's kept fans coming back for more
[Music]
thank you